the screenwriter is Michael Mitnick this
script was on the blacklist the annual
online list of best unproduced
screenplays my understanding is that
when you came aboard
Benedict Cumberbatch was already
attached how did this script find its
way to you in the most boring
traditional Hollywood way it was
submitted I was developing a few things
after me and Earl and there was one in
particular was taking a little longer
and and I wanted to read start reading
material and at first I read this and
didn't fully get it because I wasn't
that interested in electricity you know
which is odd but but I couldn't shake it
it was all the other layers that were
there about ego and humility and
ambition how far you'll go to be
remembered and and I think I was still
it was still fresh off of Earl and it
was very much obsessed with or trying to
process grief in my own life and I think
responded to subconsciously now there's
been a little time for me to be able to
see myself a little more of myself in it
but there was a lot of trying to
integrate loss and understand that and
and and and at some point I just felt
like I needed to do it if I could do it
the way I wanted to which was getting a
period piece and just like
deconstructing it and making it look
like in contemporary film because it
should from a point of view of scale
obviously we're talking about something
very different from me and or all a
dying girl to film you just mentioned
which by the way won grand prize at
Sundance how did you kind of prepare
yourself for the bigger undertaking you
know just from a physical point of view
that this was well I surrounded myself
with amazing artists some I knew some I
did not and look I've I've been raised
luckily I started as a PA eventually
made my way to a second unit director
and and was exposed to some of the big
big sets and so the scale is something I
only wanted but when you experience a
little bit that's the kind of every time
when you're a kid and you're thinking of
being a director you think it's gone
with the wind you know what you think
it's massive it's Apocalypse Now and so
I always loved that but ultimately it's
it's zet it's as intimate as Earl
because ultimately it's you looking to
an actor's eyes
and and so much prep has been done with
the key people that you're making the
movie with and and they're off creating
making that real so by the time you get
to set you have the opportunity to just
create an atmosphere that's that's
that's safe for an actor and it's all
about that moment and find the truth and
that you have two incredible
oscar-nominated actors at the heart of
this film Benedict Cumberbatch and
Michael Shannon what was most excited
exciting for you about working with them
and did you find their working methods
similar to each other or different well
they were ACDC
in real life their process is completely
different and that was a treat I love
actors I absolutely adore actors I think
one time I think someone asked Mike
Nichols onson when he was rehearsing one
of his plays he was directing how do
they do what they do
he's like you'll never know it is a
miracle it is a mystery like how he can
communicate a feeling and have them all
of a sudden the extension of that
imagination they make it real it just I
don't get it but I love being right
there for it and yeah Edison because we
had the luxury it was basically shot the
film shot two movies the Edison movie
and then the Westinghouse film and they
only share or one scene together one and
a half a little bit in the courtroom
right and the final scene I love
watching their body language together
being in the same said they didn't
interact much they just kept her
distance from each other which I loved
so those moments at the end at the at
the Pavilion in it the World's Fair
there they're really connecting for the
first time fresh while we're rolling the
camera that was gorgeous stuff but um
you know they Benedict and they have
their own process they have they
approach the material a different way
they would challenge it in different
ways and it is to be in tune with what
makes it safe for them and and and it's
always you know one person could be a
little more experimental one person's
changes could be very nuanced one would
that be both are very nuanced I think we
see with Benedict you the text is a
little more alive and we did have the
luxury of rehearsal so we
Challenge the scenes and I think maybe
maybe because of Shannon's theater
background we very much respected
detects it was just how to understand
every single word and how to explore the
nuances in the spaces between them and
one's more extroverted ones way more
introverted and and being an introvert I
know what that is and being the person I
want to be which is Edison but I'm not
you know but but but it was always fun
to see to just to play with both of them
how about all the spectacle of the of
the Expo you know because that is just
so amazing to see on screen is that all
is that a mix of practical and there was
one building that we shot mostly that's
where a lot of our visual effects money
went mostly there's it
it's a side of one building called the
Alexander palace I think and that's it
so we used that which is very similar to
the architecture at the Chicago World's
Fair the the electricity pavilion and
used that as much as we could and and
then we had the the reverse was London
and I couldn't do anything there so we
would we would extend that way and a lot
of their images were were inspired by
the few photographs that are available
from the World's Fair 1893 because the
following World's Fair of motion picture
already existed so there's a lot of
footage and at times I was tempted to
use some real footage in in the
triptychs they would make no sense so so
whatever we had we tried to be kind of
take from that and there aren't very
many of them they just had to be very
carefully storyboarded and designed and
then it came together like a puzzle
I'll find so it's great to talk to you
thank you all so much for being here
today